well there was gathering on the strip
tonight just a few hours after the
verdict was read 8 news now reporter
madison kimbrough continues our team
coverage near the las vegas strip
madison yeah denise many of those who
gathered here tonight felt today was
monumental for the floyd family
and in their eyes justice was served a
dangerous act find the defendant guilty
it's a verdict that's been nearly a year
in the making
and many in las vegas have kept their
eye on this trial from the start
they shared their thoughts tonight it
was unfair that that man lost his life
for something so petty i think it
personally could have been
things could have happened different
there were so many officers there they
could have held them down without
actually
doing what they did you know when this
first case first started last year was
emotional for a lot of people
particularly myself because i'm a mom of
three black sons who happen to be in
college
and so justice is being served with this
verdict a gathering was held on the
strip tonight to remember george floyd
and all lives lost to police brutality
the group
more than a hashtag set everything up
and let a march down the strip
and several followed with flags and
signs in tow this is just a reminder to
keep going
to keep fighting it doesn't stop
fortunately he got a piece of justice
but people are being killed every day
we're still being killed we felt we
couldn't just sit at home you know
that's one thing to do
and it's great to stay on facebook but
you have to be out you have to be active
and you know for us our next step is to
ask these leaders of our local community
and say hey what do you need from us
now chauvin faces up to 40 years in
prison for second degree murder
25 years for third degree murder and up
to 10 years for second-degree
manslaughter
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now